When I sit down and read
I'm, I'm gaining more words.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here.
And, um, today I want to talk about
reading and language learning.
So if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe and click on
the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
Now, for those of you who have been
following my channel, you know,
that I emphasize listening and
reading as being the most important
activities for acquiring a language.
Of course, we want to speak, we
eventually want to speak a lot.
Our goal is to speak.
We want to speak well, but the
emphasis should be on listening and
reading because it's something we
can do whenever we want on our own.
And it really does help our brain
become familiar with the language.
Uh, if you want to read up on it you
should check out language acquisition
with Stephen Krashen K R A S H E
N, who is in my view, the leading
explainer of how we learn languages.
So I did a video on listening in French
and it has been very well received.
And so, uh, I'm going to do videos on the
subject of listening in other languages,
maybe Spanish, Japanese, Chinese.
Let me know what you would like to hear.
Of course, I can't necessarily do
it all that well in the languages
that I don't speak as well, but
today I want to focus on reading.
Uh, you'll notice in behind
me is a new backdrop.
It shows a bookshelf.
So I have two backdrops.
I have my wooden plank backdrop,
which is in behind, and I have my
bookshelf backdrop because I love books.
So I love reading.
I think reading is a
phenomenal technology.
Uh, if we think that that humans did
not have the ability to read for most
of our existence, as, I mean, if you
go back before homosapiens, uh, I mean,
for the amount of time that hominids
or whatever they're called have been on
this, uh, earth during the whole process
of evolution, there was no reading.
And so all of a sudden, as humankind
developed this technology of representing
words and thought through symbols, which
started however many years ago, and
I'm not going to go into the history
of writing, but there have been many
writing systems today in the world.
There are many writing systems,
all of a sudden humans, our brains
have to develop this ability to
convert symbols into meaning into
perhaps sound perhaps meaning.
And, um, it's amazing that our brains
have become very good at doing this.
It's not a simple task, I think,
although I'm not a, any kind of a
cognitive scientist, uh, I find that
if I want to, you know, learn how to
do something or learn about anything,
reading is the fastest way to get there.
Uh, listening is great because I
can do that while doing other tasks.
Reading I have to basically commit
myself to reading this thing, but with
reading, I can take notes and reading
is, it's this wonderful sense that, that
these symbols are being converted into
meaning and are somehow miraculously by
our brains using sort of a capability
that for most of our history, as,
as you know, beings, we didn't have.
And it's certainly true that, that
developing the ability to read well is one
of the greatest sort of things that we can
do to ensure that we can be successful.
You know, academically,
professionally and so forth.
Reading is tremendously powerful.
That's not to say that you
can't learn through experience.
I know many people who are not great
readers, but who, you know, develop
through their experiences working with
machines or around any other kind of
thing where they accumulate experience
through watching other people do things.
And then they do them themselves and
they develop a tremendous ability,
which makes them very successful humans.
But reading is a shortcut.
Reading is tremendously powerful and
there's all kinds of statistics that
show that how well we read is a bigger
indicator of let's call it economic,
social success, professional success,
even than the number of years spent,
uh, in school or at universities.
So reading is powerful.
The same is true for language learning.
I like listening.
It's so easy to do.
I spend more time listening than
anything else because it's so easy to do.
Um, but I realized when I sit down
and read I'm, I'm gaining more
words like vocabulary acquisition is
easier through reading than through
listening, at least in my experience.
Because in a way, the sort of visual
representation of a word is, is the
written form of that word to me, rather
than whatever that word represents.
So it would be, if it were English,
R E D rather than the color red.
So the written word is a powerful
representative of the word and if
I have that in my brain, I find
it easier to remember vocabulary.
That's part of what makes learning Persian
and Arabic more difficult because I'm
not yet so comfortable with that script
that I can automatically call up the sort
of written representation of the word.
But so reading, I, and I, I say to
myself, I want to do more reading
and as with all of our activities
in languages, variety is good.
So I read on my iPad using LingQ there.
I can look words up.
I can listen in the case of Persian
and Arabic, where the pronunciation
is not always obvious, which is also
obviously the case in English that
the pronunciation is not obvious, text
to speech, and I can hear the word
pronounced and that'll help me read it.
So there's a number of reasons why
reading on the iPad, reading in LingQ,
saving words  and phrases is an easier
way for me to read, but at the same time,
I think it's good to read paper books.
And when I was learning, say Slavic
languages and even say Polish or
Czech, I would enjoy reading paper
books, even Romanian, where my
vocabulary was more limited because
I was so familiar with the alphabet.
It's more difficult for me to
do that in Persian and Arabic.
So I'm still at the stage
where I need, I'm still riding
a tricycle, training wheels.
I'm still at the stage where I need
the assist of LingQ, looking up words,
hearing the word pronounced this kind
of thing in order to enjoy reading.
But still I do find that, whereas
I would, you know, tend to say,
listen to a podcast, you know, From
Al-Jazeera now that more and more
content is being, uh, you know, pushed
at us on LingQ in terms of things
that we can import for our own use.
And a lot of that is
say newspaper articles.
I find it quicker to just take that
newspaper article and read it in
LingQ rather than going through the
process of grabbing a YouTube video,
taking the URL and getting the MP3
file and getting it transcribed.
And so forth and so on, where
listening is easy and it's powerful,
powerful for getting us sort of
momentum in the language for training
us towards speaking the language.
I associate listening with speaking and
reading with vocabulary acquisition.
Of course, both are involved in both.
So reading helps you speak
because you're acquiring more
words, listening helps you read.
But if I were to say, what is the
sort of emphasis in listening?
It's speaking.
What is the emphasis in reading?
It's vocabulary acquisition.
And so I just wanted to, and I will
continue making videos about listening and
the importance of listening, but I don't,
I don't want to deemphasize reading and,
uh, while reading is not something you
can do while you're doing other tasks,
like is the case with listening, it's
something that's relatively portable and
you can do it when you have 15 minutes or
10 minutes, or you're waiting somewhere.
And so you can read either because you
have a book paper book, or because you
have your iPhone and you can just start
reading say in the language that you're
learning, whether on LingQ or some
other, uh, website that you're following.
So reading.
Okay.
Extremely important in
language acquisition.
And, um, but with that, I will
try to do more videos in different
languages about the power of listening.
And if you have some requests
there, please let me know.
Thank you for listening.